la solitude c'est quoi si on regarde la
définition du Larousse voilà ce qu'on
trouve solitude état de quelqu'un qui
est seul momentanément ou habituellement
exemple profiter d'un instant de
solitude pour réfléchir aimer la
solitude de état de quelqu'un qui est
psychologiquement seul exemple solitude
morale donc la solitude c'est être seul
on n pas très avancé mais on note quand
même deux choses d'abord on aborde la
notion d'être psychologiquement seul et
de solitude morale ce qui implique que
la solitude c'est aussi une histoire de
ressenti et donc qu'on peut se sentir
seul même s'il y a du monde autour
ensuite la définition elle considère pas
d'emblé la solitude le fait d'être seul
comme quelque chose de négatif les
exemples du départ c'est même des
situations positives on parle même
d'aimer la solitude et c'est en ça que
je vous disais qu'il y a plusieurs forme
de solitude celle qu'on choisit et celle
qu'on subit celle qui est temporaire et
celle qui dure celle qu'on vit et celle
qu'on ressent et donc celle qui fait du
bien et celle qui fait du mal et donc
évidemment selon tous les cas de figure
elle est plus ou moins bien vécue